c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
hier soir la télé j'avais le choix entre
le match des bleus ou dirty dancing et
devinez ce que j'ai regardé dirty
dancing c'est toujours un succès ça
marche toujours
insérer sa salle danse on laisse pas
bébé tout seul dans son coin
ares et ça il dit saint patrick swayze
sûr c'est vrai je te fasse le porter
vas-y away aller
[Applaudissements]
y a pas osé il n'a pas osé tu veux le
refaire
oui je vais faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fin de l'émission
non mais là il faut un fenwick ce prix
tient du fleuve avaient salué sa des
flingues l'été
[Musique]